hello everybody and welcome back to just
a quick basic security script where
we're going to what we've got it doing
now is clicking here typing sign tags
hitting Enter and now we've arrived on
the page but we still want to actually
login so next thing we need to do is
once we arrive on this page we want to
come down here and click something but
how but what if if we just say ok click
this right after this chances are like
the loading time is going to take longer
than Sakuni like Sakuni is going to go
very fast whereas the the loading time
of syntax com might not be fast enough
so what you want to do is actually wait
until the page loads so what's a good
way for that well the way we're going to
log in here is just going to go here the
members chart is going to say you're not
a member and then we're going to login
so um what we really need a way for is
this button to be here right so
Sakuni makes it pretty simple we want to
wait until it sees this button once it
sees that button it needs to hover over
the button and then subsequently wait
for the dropdowns so now we want to say
hover and we want it to hover over this
waiting for so wait where is we waiting
for
oops let's see if we can get paint hold
on we'll try it one more time this time
we got to beat it where's wait there it
is waiting for there we go
waiting for this
then once that appears we want to move
our mouse to member charts and click it
so now we want to do is this might be
kind of difficult let's see here click
there we go cool
click members charts ok let's see if we
can make it this far so far so let's go
ahead and save where we are now and
we'll run it and let's see so goes sent
XCOM oh shoot since we're already on the
page it went but ok we're still getting
it though so it's clicked on members
charts and now it's like oh you're not a
member uh here's the subscription
information play obviously there's this
button here we're already a member we
want to log in so now what we want to do
is first of all we need to do another
wait since we're waiting for this thing
to load and sakuni is quick so we want
to wait until we spot login once we do
we want to go ahead and click login and
then once you click login we'll just
click it now we need to wait and what
we're waiting for is a login box so
let's go ahead and say we want to wait
for this box
hopefully it'll see yeah the area ok so
we wait for that once that's there we
want to click in that username field so
once it's there we're going to click
right in there and then as soon as we
click there we're going to type and
forget what I made
it's like securely - is the username I
made and then once we click or we type
once we type that now we want to come
down here and type in the password so
next thing we want to do is click um
underneath my password and now we want
to tight and I believe the password I
set for this account was just so cool so
we do that and now we want to login
after we've typed out the past
so now I'm going to make a few more
lines so you can see easily so now we
want it we've typed in password when I
hit login so now we want to click login
and so that should be it let's let's go
ahead and just go back to google.com
real quick and now we'll go ahead and
play this from the beginning let's see
if we had any problems save all right so
syntax calm waiting there it is
sees it wait comes down to members
charts clicks that bad boy waiting for
the charts and we got to fail here on
wait for login what do I failed on the
waiting part for the login list so you
cannot find it's interesting that it
would say that on a wait though like
obviously you couldn't find it I believe
there's a sleep function let's try and
add a sleeper just maybe it's like
taking too long so let's sleep like five
seconds I'm pretty sure that's just it
firstly let's go back to Google try it
one more time see what we get so far as
doing everything else pretty well there
we go that time I found the login now
it's finding this cooee to securely logs
in there we go
that's good all right cool so now we've
made a simple program that you know
visits a website logged into the website
and whatnot so by now you probably are
getting somewhat comfortable with soo
coolly and stuff those are just kind of
the basics of Sakuni now you can use it
to off all kinds of things and as time
goes on I'll probably put up some more
advanced tutorials of Sakuni but for the
most part the purpose of Sakuni is to
save you a lot of time because as you
can imagine doing like this first of all
we wrote this is you know it's a 15 line
program and we wrote it in about like I
don't know 5 10 minutes or something
like that whereas if you wrote this
within Python
it'd be like a few hundred lines
probably and it would take you quite a
while so anyways it's good for just
rapid development of just a testing
script that you just want to see like is
this even going to work for me so
anyways as always thank you for watching
thank you for your support your
subscriptions and it selects